Land und
[Musik]
Precht schönen guten Morgen Richard
guten Morgen Markus wo erreiche ich dich
am altbewährten Ort ich habe mal wieder
hin und her
geräumt janu ist ja ein großer
aufräummonat aufgeräumt und hin und her
aufräumen ist ja leider bei mir
vielleicht auch bei alligen anderen
Menschen in erster Linie hin und her
Räumen ja also man räumt immer einen
Raum auf auf Kosten eines anderen ich
hatte mal alles was ich in der Kemenate
angestaut hatte und zu viel war und das
war sehr viel in einen Zwischenraum
deponiert und wenn mal sowas da ist also
eine Deponie ja dann wächst die auch in
kürzester Zeit ganz ganz beträchttig an
vor allen wenn man Bücher schreibt und
dann alles was man man gelesen hat und
nicht mehr braucht da auch noch mit
deponiert und ich möchte in dem
Zusammenhang einen hochproblematischen
Menschen äh zitieren über den ich mit
dir etwas länger sprechen will vor
allenen über sein Hauptwerk
Oswald Spengler heißt der Mann 1880
geboren mhm hat nach dem Ersten
Weltkrieg in zwei Hälften sein Hauptwerk
geschrieben der Untergang des
Abendlandes und es ist einfach gut mal
über das Buch zu reden weil es wird so
viel und so oft in letzter Zeit zitiert
weil es natürlich sehr gut zur
Endzeitstimmung die wir im Augenblick
haben fast und so viele Leute das Gefühl
haben alles geht im Bach unter und ist
das nicht sozusagen diese alte Schinken
heute wieder das Buch der Stunde ganz
genau ich habe das Vergnügen gehabt
dieses sehr dicke und sehr sehr
umständliche Buch zweimal zu lesen also
h es sind viele Seiten ne es sind sehr
sehr viele Seiten ich habe es hier vor
mir liegen es ist eine
dünndruckausgabe die ich habe und die
hat
1240 Seiten stellber und äh ich gebe
auch zu es gibt so einige Passagen und
Kapitel über antike Hochkulturen die
habe ich mir geschenkt und zwar beim
ersten Mal und auch beim zweiten Mal es
steht auch sonst noch genug da drin
worüber es sich lohnt sich viele
Gedanken zu machen ja und es ist
wirklich interessant weil wir führen
dieses dieses dieses dieses Wort diese
Rede führen wir ja führen wir ständig im
im Mund ja wir sagen ja ständig ist der
Untergang des Abendlandes so ein
feststehender Begriff ja das Abendland
ist wieder aufgetaucht ne so wieder hat
das Wort Abendland wieder exhumiert und
ich würde mich sehr wundern wenn man
dabei nicht an Spengler gedacht hat denn
das Buch war in bestzeller das hat sich
viele zehntausende Male verkauft das
wurde in der Weimarer Republik in aller
Munde geführt also wahrscheinlich hat es
keiner gelesen weil es so ein
kompliziertes Buch ist ja aber jeder
wusste so ungefähr was drin steht weißt
du was ja was echt interessant ist ist
du hast mir irgendwann davon erzählt und
dann liest man jetzt die wirklich wenn
du meinungsstücke liest wenn du wenn du
auch die Qualitätspresse liest und so
weiter das taucht ständig auf also diese
beiden Dinge der Untergang des
Abendlandes dieses spenglerbuch ähm und
und sozusagen der der der Querverweis
auf die auf die neuen Rechten und
der der Vergleich mit der Weimarer
Republik und ich habe mir dann mal die
Mühe gemacht ich habe das gekauft habe
mir das angeguckt ich bin sehr früh
gescheitert nach wenigen Seiten hatte
ich ehrlich gesagt keinen Bock mehr auf
dieses Buch weil es wirklich mühsam ist
und ich fand es interessant wie
größenwahnsin nicht dieses Buch schon
anfängt das fängt fängt so Größen
wahnsinnig an dass er sagt in diesem
Buch ist glaube ich sogar der erste Satz
wird zum ersten mal der Versuch
unternommen Geschichte vorherzusagen
oder
vorauszubestimmenig verrückt also er
sagt sozusagen Geschichte ist sonst
immer der Blick nach hinten aber jetzt
mache ich den Versuch und sage euch wie
es mit euch weiter geht gen das ist der
erste Satz der Einleitung genau und den
die Biografie ich schaue mir auf die
Biografien von Menschen an weil man so
eine Idee davon kriegt wer jemand
eigentlich ist geboren 1880 ein ein
Privatgelehrter wie du schon sagtest
umfass Postbeamten ja der sich das alles
alles selber drauf geschaufelt hat also
der hat sich mit allen ein ein irgendwas
zwischen universal Gelehrter und
universal
diletant also irgendwo so in niemands
Land dazwischen genau so und gilt
sozusagen als wenn man so will einer der
urväterrechten autoritären Denkens
zwischendurchöllig gess genau des
modernen ultrarechten konservativismusau
richtig und es gibt diesen diesen Satz
von von Adorno auch sehr berühmter Mann
der sagt der vergessene Spengler Recht
sich indem er droht Recht zu behalten so
und die die interessante These von
Spengler eine der zentralen Thesen war
das Buch ist ja erstmal so gar nicht so
so rechts so wie wir das verstehen
würden ja da da stehen viele auch sehr
gescheite Sätze drin ja und und die
These war aber die Demokratie die wird
verschwinden das ist quasi nur eine eine
Reaktion auf auf den ersten Weltkrieg
und auf das dieses erschrecken darüber
und so weiter und irgendwann wird das
Verschwinden und dann kommt ein
cesarismus wie er das nennt also
autoritäre die auf dem vormarch sind und
du und du guckst dich um und denkst
warte mal Putin Ching Ping
erdoanor Orban victtor Orban selbst bei
jemand wie makron könnte man wenn man
böse ist sagen auch manchmal sowas le
autoritäres ja sagt an ne mhm also
sozusagen die Sehnsucht nach jemandem
der mal kommt und mal richtig auf den
Tisch haut ja so und zwar mit der
Begründung äh dass das Abendland also
also muss ich das so vorstellen er ist
ein großer Goethe Fan mhm und wie Goethe
in der Metamorphose der Pflanzen ja
zeigt wie quasi aus Keimen heraus so ein
Reifungsprozess stattfindet bis hin zur
Blüte und zum Verfall irgendwann wieder
die Samen kommen dann und so also
natürlicher Kreislauf Morphologie ja
alles ändert sich alles hat einen Anfang
alles hat Samen alles hat ein eine Blüte
alles hat Früchte und alles hat einen
Verfall und das überträgt Spengler auf
Kulturen und sagt das bei Kulturen genau
dasselbe und dann geht er hin und
forstet alle antiken Kulturen und sagt
ne wann stand Rom am stärksten in Blüte
zu welcher Zeit war das und wodurch kam
der Verfall und dann versucht ein Muster
herauszuarbeiten und überträgt das auf
das Abendland und sagt das entstand im
frühen Mittelalter quasi zur Zeit der
Franken ne der Miro winger und Karl dem
Großen und so da entstand das was wir
das Abendland heute nennen das
christliche Abendland und das Erreichte
sein Höhepunkt so im 18 Jahrhundert also
vor der Französischen Revolution noch
mhm und seitdem gibt es vollnness und
dekadenzerscheinungen und eine absolute
vollnness und dekadenzerscheinung ist
die Demokratie und das begründet er wie
folgt er sagt
das ist übrigens ein Bild was viel älter
ist als Spengler das findet man auch bei
vielen Konservativen schon im späten 18
Jahrhundert zur Zeit der französischen
Revolution wie dem wie kommt de bonald
ja ein hochintelligenter konservativer
Gegner der französischen Revolution die
sagen ist doch völlig klar was passiert
wenn also die Zeit der Aristokraten und
der Geistes Aristokraten vorbei ist und
dann kommt die Demokratie was dann
passiert ist die Herrschaft des Geldes
und die Herrschaft des Geldes wird über
kurz oder lang dazu führen dass jeder
nur noch an sein persönliches vkommen
denkt und dann löst sich der Kit in
einer Gesellschaft auf
und Motor des Fortschritts wird da nicht
mehr die Kraft die Energie weißt du
alles das ja was aus der Morphologie
übernimmt ne von göte ne die Lebenskraft
sondern im Grunden geht es nur noch um
die eigenen Interessen und um die
Technik sehr interessant dass die
Konservativen waren immer enorm
technikskeptisch und sagen die Leute
beten dann irgendwann die Technik an und
den technischen Fortschritt und was sie
wirklich noch richtig begeistert ist
eigentlich nur noch das Geld und das ist
jetzt eine Analyse die er auch aus allen
möglichen Quellen zusammenträgt wir
haben ja hier mal geredet über die
Philosophie des Geldes von Georg Simmel
wo Georg Simmel eben auch sagt ne dass
das Geld in den modernen Gesellschaften
an die Stelle der Ehre getreten istm ne
und das ist was sozusagen das zentrale
Element von freiheitlichen Demokratien
ist also Kapitalismus und freiheitliche
Demokratie ist ja nicht zu trennen und
das Geld spielt dabei eine irrsinnige
Rolle und jetzt sagt Spengler ja aber
weil das eben so ist führt das dazu dass
irgendwie die Gesellschaft immer
morscher wird und dass sie ihre Kraft
ihre Lebenskraft verliert und diese
Lebenskraft verpufft ja die Gesellschaft
wird dekadent die Leute laufen nur noch
dem Geld hinterher es gibt keinen
völkischen Zusammenhang mehr und keinen
Zusammenhalt mehr und auf diese Art und
Weise muss an der Vielfalt der
Partikularinteressen und an der
verstätterung den unübersichtlichen
Großstädten wo die Leute auf die
dümmsten Ideen kommen und dann alledem
muss das dann irgendwann in lauter
Dekadenz Zug Grunde gehen und so wie ich
das gerade zusammengefasst hat
glaube ich gäbe es den einen oder
anderen Parteivertreter der AFD der sagt
ja so ist es ja ich ich ich mal abseits
der AFD ich glaube das ist ein Gefühl
dass viele gerade haben so diese diese
diese Dekadenz diese
Wohlstandsverwahrlosung ist auch so ein
Wort dass man häufig hört ich habe Dirk
kurbioweit der der spiegelchefredakteur
hat neulich auch darüber geschrieben ist
ein toller Autor fin der sollte viel
mehr schreiben als Chef vom Spiegel sein
weil er so ein großartiger Schreiber ist
und der der sagt in einem langen Stück
dazu
dass Demokratie und Kapitalismus
brauchen beide Freiheit um zu
funktionieren und das ist der Grund
warum Demokratie und Kapitalismus also
beide Menschen die sehr weit rechts
draußen unterwegs sind und eben auch
jemand wie Spengler verdächtig sind
genau weil aus der Sichtweise von
rechtskonservativen ist Freiheit
Zügellosigkeit und Regellosigkeit
Kontrollverlust und aften die zügellos
und regellos sind müssen irgendwann zu
Grunde gehen das ist sozusagen das
grundaktion dahinter genau das das total
interessant das ist die eine parallele
die zweite und da da schluckst du
wirklich wenn du das liest Spengler
beschreibt ich meine diese Bücher sind
beiden beide Bände ne ich glaube 1918
und 1922
erschienen und wie ich schon sagte ne
die der Untergang des Abendlandes ich
meine wie oft benutzen wir diese diese
die diese flosklis ist ja mittlerweile
schon so Redewendung
das ist auch der Untergang des
Abendlandes Abendlandes so genau und
ohne zu wissen was was wir da eigentlich
zitieren und
was er dort auch beschreibt ist
ein zweiten Komplex der sozusagen unsere
Gesellschaft bedroht nämlich der
Gegensatz zwischen Stadt und Land und da
schlst und und denkst warte mal wann ist
das Buch erschienen Stadt und Land und
er sagt der Stadtmensch ja hat selber
auch in der Stadt gelebt nebenbei aber
diese Art von widersprüchlichke glaube
ich kein Problem sorgt für eine
entsetzliche Entvölkerung weil er keine
Kinder mehr haben will ja und dann kommt
dieser Satz die bis zum Äußersten
gesteigerte Intelligenz findet keine
Gründe mehr für ihr weiteres
Vorhandensein von Kindern das kein
richtig schlechter Satz finde ich ne ne
ne interessant ist auch also schon
richtig man darf nicht zu lange über die
Frage nachdenken wann und ob man Kinder
kriegen will weil am Ende kriegt man
dann keine das ist nicht ganz verkehrt
und man ahnt es schon der großgelehrte
Spengler hatte selbst ständlich selbst
keine Kinder und hat sich den Haushalt
von seiner Schwester machen lassen ja so
aber das ist interessant dass der damals
schon das gesehen hat und pass auf wenn
du wenn du folgenden Satz hörst der
Bauer ist für diese Großstädter kein
Demokrat folglich übersieht belächelt
verachtet und hasst man ihn die Welt
wird in den Metropolen gestaltet die
Provinz kann nicht mitreden und kann
höchstens zu vollzogenen Ereignissen
Stellungen nehmen genau und da haben wir
die ganze hast die bauernproteste da
hast du die
elitenverdrossenheit die du genauso im
mittleren Westen der USA hast wieso sie
in vielen Teilen des Ostens unseres
Landes hast in Frankreich hast du jetzt
Bauern Proteste auch nach dem ähnlichen
Gusto wobei man sagen muss auch ein
totaler Zentralstaat ne kein föderaler
Staat Frankreich ne da geht ja wirklich
alles wesentlich in Paris ab und sonst
was nichts also krasser als es in
Deutschland ist und das ist tatsächlich
die die Landbevölkerung hat ein anderes
Zeitgefühl ja hat ich habe ja auch schon
mal als wir über die Bauern geredet
haben sagen Bauer ist ein konservativer
Beruf und es wundert nicht dass die
Bauern von sehr sehr wenigen Ausnahmen
vielleicht Bauernkrieg zur Zeit Martin
Luthers oder so eigentlich eher zu den
Bremsern der Geschichte gehört haben und
nie zu den Vorreitern ja Revolutionen
gehen eigentlich nie vom Lande aus
sondern sie gehen von Intellektuellen in
Städten aus die dann verzweifelt
versuchen die Land Bevölkerung hinter
sich zu kriegen was dann meistens nicht
funktioniert mm weil es weil es dann
auch zu spät ist ne und interessant ist
ja auch dass Spengler ähnlich wie wir es
dann 2016 bei jemandem wie Trump erlebt
haben der ist selber gleichzeitig elitär
und antielitär ist wahnsinnig elitär ja
schreibt wie Gothe ja ist ein Goethe
Bewunderer und er sieht sich stilistisch
aber verachtet diese diese Eliten von
denen er selbst natürlich ein Teil ist
in intellektueller Hinsicht sowieso ja
weil es die falschen Eliten sind ja das
sind die die geldeliten die die
geldeliten die
freiheitseliten ja und der Milliardär
Trump kriegt es hin sich zum Anwalt
kleiner Bauern in Kansas oder oder in
Michigan oder wo auch immer zu machen
und dieser Widerspruch stört da dann
aber auch keinen mehr das ist das ist
quasi aufgelöst dann nächster Punkt auch
total interessant Spengler mochte die
Presse nicht das war für ihn geistige
Artillerie ja und und vermutet dahinter
sozusagen die Macht des Geldes die die
Presse verbreitet nicht auch so ein
spenglersatz sondern sie erzeugt die
freie Meinung ja und auch das ist ja
nicht in jedem Fall falsch nee das ich
meine Harald Welzer und ich haben ja ein
Buch darüber geschrieben gesagt es ist
eben eine komplizierte Angelegenheit ne
und das tut sie durchaus es ist auch ihr
Selbstverständnis ja bestimmte Meinungen
zu verbreiten oder Meinungen
durchzusetzen ja weil sie auch Haltung
zeigen will weil sie auch eigene
Überzeugungen hat und so weiter ja mm
aber auch da wieder die die die Analogie
zu heute ne also wie viele Menschen hast
du mittlerweile die sagen die die
klassischen Medien lese ich nicht mehr
ich lese keinen Spiegel mehr ich lese
keine Süddeutsche mehr ich lese die FAZ
nicht mehr und ich schaue auch nicht die
Tagesschau und was die heute Nachrichten
mir erzählen schaue ich auch nicht und
Klammer auf ich glaube es auch alles
nicht Klammer zu weil die erzählen das
was ihnen Politiker vorgeben genau weil
hinter steht dahinter steht die die
Erzählung dass das alles sei gesteuert
die Regierung zieht an den Fäden und die
Presse zappelt hinterher ja und und
verbreitet das ganze das ist dieser
berühmte Lügenpresse Vorwurf und auch da
muss ich reingrchen und sagen dass
Harald und ich uns viel Mühe gegeben
haben den zu entkräften und zu sagen so
funktioniert das nicht nee und es es es
gibt ja auch tatsächlich eine Menge
Journalisten Kolleginnen Kollegen die
sagen wir mal also manchmal gelingt es
ja wirklich Wahrheit aufzuspüren und
sehr häufig aber gelingt ist sehr gut
Wirklichkeiten zu beschreiben und das
ist das was was funktioniert aber an an
Wirklichkeit oder gar an Wahrheit haben
natürlich Rechtspopulisten überhaupt
kein Interesse die haben eine andere Art
anderen
Wahrheitsbegriff also das ist doch das
interessante wenn wenn Menschen starke
politische Überzeugung haben dann ich
habe das auch beim letzten Mal gesagt
dann passen sie ihre Überzeugung ihren
Gefühlen an und Wahrheit ist wenn meine
Überzeugung mit meinen Gefühlen
übereinstimmt
das heißt ich setze einen
Wahrheitsanspruch den ich emotional
selbst
bewähre und das ist der klassische
Mechanismus der politischen
Willensbildung man müsste sich mal
vorstellen man würde versuchen als
jemand der sich mit Parteipolitik noch
nie irgendwie beschäftigt hat mit den
Mitteln der Logik herauszufinden was
gute und richtige Politik ist rein
rational das würde überhaupt nicht
funktionieren weil hinter allen
politischen Überzeugungen stehen
Emotionen die sich zu verballen
verdichten zu Weltanschauungen mhm zu
Liberalen Weltanschauung konservativen
linksprogressiven und so weiter und so
weiter aber im Grunde genommen geht es
ja eigentlich immer nur darum die
Weltanschauung zu seinen Gefühlen zu
finden mhm und bei den Rechten ist ja
sind bestimmte Axiome gesetzt also
schwengler sagt ne der hat diese Theorie
es geht um die
Lebenskraft sind damals total beliebter
Begriff wir haben mal über Henri beron
gesprochen ja der auch von dieser von
dem Elan Val von der Lebenskraft
schreibt wenn auch im anderen
Zusammenhang das ist so so typisch
gewesen damals hat die Biologie noch mit
dem Begriff der Lebenskraft gearbeitet
weil man sich nicht erklären konnte was
denn letztlich das Wachstum auslöst was
das Leben ist welche Dynamik dahinter
ist und diese biologischen Bilder die
wurden wie Spengler das auch gemacht hat
im Fall von Goethe übertragen auf die
Gesellschaft mhm und dahinter ist der
Wille zur Macht wie das bei nietser
heißt ja also jedes Volk jede Nation ja
hat wie jede Tierpopulation das
Bedürfnis sich auszubreiten sich
durchzusetzen und und und und die
Demokratie in den Augen Spenglers ja die
zerlabert das die zerflückt das die
macht das kaputt die natürliche Energie
des Volkes die wird quasi gestört und
zerstört durch Demokratie und das ist
auch ein zeitloser Gedanke rechten
Denkens dass diese Lebenskraft sich
ausdrückt in dem Willen zur Expansion in
dem Willen zur Herrschaft in dem Willen
zur Macht und das ist klassische Rechte
DNA spätestens seit Spengler aber
eigentlich schon davor interessant ist
ja ich mE das klingt so ein bisschen wie
soll man sagen das du sagst es in sehr
wohl formuliert und das klingt sch ein
bisschen abgehoben
im Sinne von gut was hat das mit mir zu
tun hat eine Menge mit uns allen zu tun
und interessant ist in dem Zusammenhang
über den Begriff von Kausalität zu
sprechen über Ursache und Wirkung das
ist ja etwas worüber wir in unseren
Gesellschaften ganz viel reden also
warum warum der ukrainekrieg was ist die
Ursache was ist die Wirkung wer hat ihn
ausgelöst wer ist schuld und so weiter
und daraus entwickelt sich ja im Zweifel
auch quasi eine Art Moral und Spengler
war ja offenbar jemand und das hast du
auch bei ganz vielen rechten ich habe
das auch bei Interviews in Amerika
gesehen wie soll mal sagen also fast
schon magisches Denken ja das meine ich
jetzt gar nicht despektierlich aber
Kinder haben magisches Denken ja Kind
Kinder denken anders ja die die die da
geht's sozusagen um du musst keine
Begründung für etwas liefern sondern
logien in
Ähnlichkeiten bestimmte Dinge die
ähnliche Gefühle auslösen werden quasi
ähnlich gespeichert ähnlich wahrgenommen
ja genau so und wenn du natürlich das
ausschaltest also das Denken Nachdenken
über Ursache und Wirkung wer war
eigentlich wirklich Schuld am Ersten
Weltkrieg wer hat den eigentlich
ausgelöst was was haben wir als
Gesellschaft als Politik möglicherweise
als Medien falsch gemacht dass diese
oder jene Entwicklung eingetreten ist
und ich meine das ist unser Job jeden
Tag genau das zu tun rechtes denken
hasast das weil da kommt an die Stelle
sozusagen von Ursache und Wirkung kommt
dieses schicksalshafte ne das ist das
ist das Schicksal des des germanischen
Volkes und oder von wem auch immer es
ist das Schicksal der weißen in den USA
und so weiter bestimmte Dinge zu tun und
und dafür muss man dann große Opfer
bringen und großes Leid und so weiter
aber alles sozusagen für eine große für
eine höhere Sache richtig das ist ja
eigentlich Religion ne das ist
sekularisierte Religion ne das also eine
Religion in der kein Gott vorkommt ne
sondern an die Stelle Gottes tritt das
Schicksal ja und des Volkes der Nation
Schicksal und Verhängnis sind ja zwei
Begriffe die ganz eng mit Religionen
Zusammenhängen ne denn denn denn was
Gott Gott ist
ja vorbestimmt und B wir können das
nicht durchschauen ne gottes Wege sind
unergründlich ne also Spengler bewahrt
sich die Unergründlichkeit des
politischen ja indem er
schicksalszusammenhänge und Kreise von
von verhängnissen und so weiter aufdeckt
und sagt das ist die eigentliche
Gestaltungskraft der Geschichte und
nicht etwas was man logisch analysieren
od rational begreifen kann also die
Arbeit der Historiker ist eigentlich
mehr oder weniger überflüssig sie könnte
vielleicht sozusagen den Weg des
Schicksals nachzeichnen aber wenn Sie
alles fein Zerlegen der hat A hat
gemacht B weil ja
geness kommen wirag groen ganzen nicht
auf die Spur ja und es ist ist der Trick
sozusagen ne auch die auch die grul der
Nazis ja wenn du wenn du wenn du Ursache
und Wirkung wenn du moralisches denken
damit ausschaltest dann brauchst du auch
nicht mehr über Schuld nachzudenken dann
bist du raus und auch die Verbindung
letzten Endes zu zu Fake News ja liegt
ja auch da hast du genau das also wer
genau hinschaut wer recherchiert wenn du
benennst dann kannst du kannst du
anfangen dir ein ein Urteil zu bilden
eine Idee von etwas zu kriegen
Verantwortung ist dann ein großes Thema
und so weiter all das willst du nicht ne
du ersetzt es einfach durch diese
schicksalshaftigkeit und dann bist Du
quasi re also du du entwertest es weil
du sagst das ist eigentlich nur Gelaber
ja und das ist das kann man alles machen
das ist ein Hobby oder ein Sport aber
das was tatsächlich die Geschichte
antreibt entzieht sich rationaler
Kategorien das ist die grundsache
übrigens ist interessant weil du gerade
von den Nazis gesprochen hast Spengler
der 36 gestorben hat also den Aufstieg
und die Herrschaft der Nazis noch erlebt
hielt nichts von den nationalsozial und
zwar waren sie ihm nicht elitär
genug also das ist das interessante er
redet von den Bauern er redet von der
Landbevölkerung er redet von der Kraft
dees Volkes aber wenn das Volk als Masse
Auftritt Masse ist ein lieblingsbegriff
der 20er Jahre ja bereits 1895 hatte
Gustav lebon auch so ein
Universalgelehrter ein Buch über die
Psychologie der Massen geschrieben und
danach hat Sigmund Freud was darüber
geschrieben und der der damals noch
linke spanische Philosoph Ortega igasset
hat diesen berühmt berühmten Essay
geschrieben der Aufstand der Massen das
war immer also bei Freud war es war es
sozusagen der Mensch verdumpft in der
Masse ja und auch bei den ander
sozusagen wenn etwas zu Masse wird dann
wird es dumm dann wird es banal ja dann
treibt es der Welt den Geist aus und
diese Massenpartei
NSDAP ja mit diesem ungebildeten Führer
an der Spitze ja diesem diesem Hallodri
ja der der nichts richtiges war der gar
kein Teil der bürgerlichen Gesellschaft
und so weiter war der Lichtjahre von
Goethe entfernt war ja das war überhaupt
kein Cesar nach den Vorstellungen von
auswalt Spengler merkwürdigerweise hat
ja Mussolini ziemlich großartig geunden
genau mm der ja sein Art mindestens
genauso derb aufgetreten ist wie hin
aber den hat er sich auf der Distanz
irgendwie schön geredet wahrscheinlich
deswegen weil er ein großer Fan des
römischen Reiches war und da nun
Mussolini Italiener war vieles also in
der Fantasie von Spengler nicht schwer
in ihm sozusagen ein wieddergänger
römischer cesaren zu sehen wogegen Adolf
Hitler der kleine Mann mit dem
Schnauzbart so überhaupt nicht aussah
wie sich schwengler einen Caesar
vorstellt die große Frage die sich daran
anschließt und darüber haben wir in
dieser Woche mit mit haradiena
gesprochen ehemaliger phtonchef der
Berlin iner Zeitung der ein großartiges
Buch geschrieben hat Wolfszeit
wahnsinniger Bestseller indem er die
Jahre zwischen 45 und 55 also genau
diese 10 Jahre so beschrieben hat so
plastisch beschrieben hat wie es noch
nie einer vorim gemacht hat eine
Gesellschaft der die Moral völlig
abhanden gekommen war die sich sozusagen
auf den Leichen und den trümern des
Zweiten Weltkriegs neu erfunden hat der
erklärt warum die trümerfrauen auf
vielen dieser Fotos so seltsam elegant
gekleidet sind warum Schwarzmärkte
psychologisch so wichtig waren und viele
viele andere Dinge der
emanzipationsschub für Frauen also all
diese Dinge die sich in diesen 10 Jahren
sozusagen abgespielt haben jetzt hat er
aktuell ein Buch gemacht
Höhenrausch das kurze Leben zwischen den
Kriegen und da geht's genau um diese
Zeit und es geht genau um diese Frage
und er sagt die wahmarer Zeit ist unser
Situation in vielen Punkten verblüffend
ähnlich und in manchen gar nicht wie
siehst du das ich sehe das genauso also
ich ich sehe Ähnlichkeiten also
zuerstmal stimmungsähnlichkeiten erstmal
ist unsere wirtschaftliche Lage deutlich
besser als zur Zeit der Weimarer
Republik man darf auch nicht vergessen
als dann am Anfang der 30er Jahre 6
Millionen Menschen keine Arbeit hatten
in Deutschland die waren auf der Straße
die Waren an den Suppenküchen ne heute
gibt es immer noch die dämliche
Redewendung man müsste die Arbeitslosen
von der Straße holen die Arbeitslosen
sind heute nicht mehr auf der Straße
richtig ja und wer keine Arbeit hat der
ist im Vergleich zur Weimarer Republik
natürlich sehr sehr viel besser gestellt
der muss auch nicht Hunger leiden und
weit ist ganz ganz andere Zeit ja selbst
wenn die Arbeitslosigkeit so hoch gehen
würde ja ist die Situation eines
Arbeitslosen damals natürlich eine
andere gewesen als heute dann haben die
Leute mit der Demokratie massiv
gefremdelt denn eigentlich war die
Demokratie damals verordnet worden ja
vom amerikanischen Präsidenten kann man
sagen in Wilsons berühmten Punkten das
heißt die Alliierten hatten den
deutschen gesagt so jetzt müsst auch mal
eine Demokratie machen und die Deutschen
hatten keine Ahnung keine Erfahrung
überhaupt keine positiven Erfahrung
damit gemacht und es war nichts was sie
selbst entwickelt hatten sondern was sie
jetzt so von außen gesagt kriegen mach
doch mal und natürlich war das nach 5
auch ja auch da konnte man nur an eine
sehr kurze demokratische Tradition
anknüpfen aber es war eine ganz andere
moralische Situation Deutschland hatte
nach 45 war der weltbösewicht schlecht
hin gewesen hatte die größten ver chen
in der Geschichte der Menschheit
beganangnen den Holocaust und auch die
Todeszahlen des Zweiten Weltkrieges 30
Millionen Menschen sind gestorben in der
Zeit des Zweiten Weltkrieges allein auf
dem Gebiet der damaligen Sowjetunion und
so weiter also unvorstellbar und die
leitende Ideologie lag komplett in
Trümmern die war total kaputt das war ja
beim Kaiserreich nicht so gewesen na da
gab's ja unheimlich viele Menschen die
dem Kaiserreich noch nachrauerten es war
ja auch in Deutschland kein Krieg
gewesen beim Ersten Weltkrieg man hatte
den Krieg in ausländischen Schütz Räben
verloren aber nicht im Heimatland
interesster im Zweiten Weltkrieg hatte
man den Verlust gesehen da waren die
Städte total bombardiert worden und so
weiter das heißt also sie man hatte am
eigenen Leib die Niederlage erfahren
beim ersten kannte man die Niederlage
vom hören sagen und hat sie nicht
richtig geglaubt es heißt die Deutschen
waren wirklich nach 45 reif für die
Demokratie und sie waren es damals nicht
gewesen und nachdem wir jetzt eine sehr
lange sehr sehr erfolgreiche Zeit der
Demokratie haben sind wir natürlich
psychisch erstmal grundsätzlich in einer
deutlich eren Situation als es die
Weimarer Republik war das würde ich mal
als Ausgangspunkt sagen ist ein
wichtiger Unterschied ja gibt einen
zweiten interessanten Punkt jener sagt
fundamental anders ist dass es in der
Weimarer Republik da gab es so ein so
ein so ein utopischen Radikalismus ja
der der im Grunde die ganze das was Du
eigentlich gerade beschrieben hast die
ganze Gesellschaft durchzogen hat und
Demokratie war auch so ein bisschen
verdächtig also auch so die
linksliberale Intelligenz wollte sich
sehr zögerlich eigentlich zu dieser zu
dieser Demokratie bekennen und so weiter
sagt das heißt eigentlich atmete er das
alles sozusagen den den Geist von von ja
von von der große Knall ja die der
einmal Big Bang äh und er sagt und der
große Unterschied zu heute ist wir wären
heute ja schon froh wenn alles einfach
so bleiben würde wie es ist mhm das ist
ein ganz wichtiger Unterschied das ist
sehr gut beobachtet also bei uns
resultiert äh die
Unzufriedenheit nicht daraus dass die
Leute sagen es muss alles anders werden
sondern aus der Angst dass sehr viele
wichtige Dinge nicht bleiben was sie
waren richtig ne also der konservative
Impuls ist ein anderer es geht
eigentlich weitgehend darum bestimmte
Errungenschaften von früher zu behalten
die man je nachdem auf welcheer welche
Sichtweise man auf die Gegenwart wirft
den Bach runtergehen sieht oder eben
nicht den Bach rtergehen sieht das war
in Weimar ganz anders die die die
Rechten Kräfte wollten den Kaiser wieder
habenm die Anzahl der Menschen die mit
der Demokratie an sich fremdelten war in
ein sehr hoch und die Anzahl der
Menschen in Deutschland die
grundsätzlich mit der Demokratie
fremdeln und da gibt's ja unheimlich
viele Umfragen zu ja die liegt
wahrscheinlich unter 10%. mm es gibt
eine irrsinnige Unzufriedenheit mit der
gegenwärtigen Regierung die vielleicht
historisch ist weil sie die größte
Unzufriedenheit mit einer amtierenden
Regierung ist seit Gründung der
Bundesrepublik aber es gibt nicht im
gleichen Ausmaß ein grundsätzliches
fremdeln mit den Prinzipien der
Liberalen dem
also obwohl wir über 20% in den Umfragen
an mutmaßlichen AFD Wählern haben haben
wir nicht 20% der Bevölkerung die die
liberale Demokratie abschaffen möchtem
richtig das sollte man auch nicht in
einem Atemzug nennen weil damit nimmt
man sich die trendschafe bei der
Beschreibung der AFD als eine sehr sehr
vielschichtige Angelegenheit ja das
Interessante ist er beschreibt das auch
in diesem Buch und deswegen empfehle ich
dass so ist ein Brillant geschriebenes
Buch weil Harald jener so so so ja so
sinnlich und plastisch einfach auch
schreiben kann sagt das Verrückte ist
1932 ging die Wirtschaftsdaten die echt
schlecht waren ging schon langsam wieder
aufwärts also es gibt so einen zarten
wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung der dennoch
deutlich zu spüren ist aber der am Ende
nicht sozusagen 33 verhindert dass die
die die Wahl von von von Adolf Hitler
und das Interessante ist 32 du kennst ja
den das reheinland sehr ser gut ich
glaube 32 ist doch die berühmte
a555 gebaut worden s die erste deutsche
autob ich meine als nicht Autofahrer ist
das für mich jetzt nicht so der ganz
wichtige historische Markstein ja aber
die Regierung Brüning hat hat die
Autobahn geplant ne also das ist keine
Erfindung Hitlers also die Pläne dafür
lagen bereits vor ja und Adenauer war
der war der Kölner Oberbürgermeister der
der hat das gemacht und das interessante
war ich ich mir das noch mal angesehen
die diese diese berühmte
plomatenrennpiste ja weil dann W man
immer zwischen Bonn und Köln hinter hin
und her ballerte und dann nicht zur
Rechenschaft gezogen werden durfte wenn
man zu schnell war Diplomatenpass ja
deswegen ja dieser dieser Name die wurde
32 gebaut und zwar mit der expliziten
Ansage weil du gerade sagst Arbeiter die
Leute von der Straße holen ja keine
Bagger zu verwenden keine Bagger und
kein anderes großes Gerät weil wir
wollen die Menschen von der von von der
Straße bringen wir wollen dass die
Menschen Arbeit haben also die Vorgabe
war das muss händisch so sehr es geht
gemacht werden damit die Leute Arbeit
haben und interessanterweise hat Aden
das gemacht nachdem man diesen diesen
wunderschönen Kölner grün W nä gerade
sagen die ist die Fortsetzung des
grünürtels mit
anderen genau man hat damals man hat
damals ja also es war ja nicht nur nicht
nur in Köln den grünenürtel man findet
man findet eigentlich in jeder größeren
Stadt Grünanlagen ja die Anfang der 30er
Jahre gebaut sind um die Arbeitslosen zu
beschäftigen richtig ist das ist das
irre oder w man sich das mal überlegt
Arbeitsbeschaffungsmaßnahmen genau genau
und interessant auch die die Geschichte
deswegen deswegen ist mir diese Autobahn
so nah nicht nicht weil ich ir so
furchtbar auf Autobahn abfahre aber die
Nazis haben diese Straße diese Autobahn
hinterher zu
einer Bundesstraße quasi um
umetikettiert damit man die schöne
Erzählung aufrecht erhalten konnte der
erste der ahn gebaut hat war
selbstverständlich der Führer genau und
damals der der Hauptgrund warum die
Autobahnen gebaut wurden war ja nicht
weil wir so wahnsinnig viele Autos gab
die so lange Strecken fahren konnten und
wollten sondern um logistische Achsen zu
schaffen für den
Krieg der Sinn der Autobahn war
Militärgerät so schnell wie möglich
transportieren zu können und das nicht
jetzt über Dorfstraßen hinweg
transportieren zu
müssen und interessant ist auch was
jener auch beschreibt der sagt das was
die Menschen den Nazis in die Arme
getrieben hat das waren weniger
sozusagen reale elendserfahrungen in in
der Weimarer Zeit sonder es waren die
Ängste davor zu ver die Angst vor
sozialem Abstieg die Angst sozusagen es
nicht mehr nach oben zu packen sondern
nach unten durchgereicht zu werden ja
und dann ich meine die die ren Ideologie
bot den Verlierern der Gesellschaft an
sich als Übermenschen zu fühlen ja und
die anderen als
Untermenschen das ist ja auch nicht
wenig gewesen also all die Leute die
ihre Arbeit verloren haben die Angst um
ihre Zukunft hatten die in schlechten
sozialen Verhältnissen leben die waren
aber immerhin noch eine Herrenrasse
wurde ihnen da eingeflüstert mm ja und
und und und die Übeltäter wurden ganz
konkret benannt und dann wurden die die
Menschen ausgegrenzt und dann
Antisemitismus und alles was damit
zusammenhängt und das traf in der
Bevölkerung auf ein waches Bedürfnis
danach ja also die Verlierer wollten
sich als Herrin fühlen ne das war
natürlich auch noch eine Droge ja eine
politische Droge
mit mit enorm Gift die da verabreicht
wurde und für die sehr viele empfängt
ich ich ich frage mich manchmal ob
sozusagen auch die die die die Tatsache
wie sich das Leben damals plötzlich
entwickelte ob die auch was damit zu tun
hat diese Entfremdung gerade das was was
Spengler auch beschreibt und was wir
heute auch so oft beschreiben ne auf der
einen Seite quasi diese die dekadente
Großstadt ja so so Babylon Berlin ja die
orgen an jeder Ecke gefühlt ja und auf
anderen Seite sozusagen das beschaeriche
Leben auf dem Lande und das eine hat mit
dem anderen nichts zu tun damals auch
das das beschreibt jener
auch wurde oder sozusagen wurden viele
Dinge ganz neu gedacht Dinge die von
Grund auf anders werden sollten die neue
Frau Bubikopf war war plötzlich das
Thema ja Frauen die sich Mode wurde
überhaupt erstmal richtiges
gesellschaftliches Thema und zwar ein
Thema nicht nur für die adelsschichten
oder industriellen gattinnentig sondern
es wurde ein Thema für jeder Mann genau
der neue Mann neues wohnen neues Denken
das ganze Thema ne baaus ja völlige
Revolution ich meine vorher hat man die
Häuser so ornamental wie möglich gebaut
eine eine bürgerliche Wohnung sollte
aussehen wie ein Schloss ja mit Stuck ja
und und Flügeltüren und auf einmal hieß
es neue Sachlichkeit Bauhaus
Schmucklosigkeit karkheit ganz neue
stilideen entstehen ja es ja in die
Kunst verändert sich radikal die moderne
Kunst entsteht ja
Expressionismus kennzeichnen für für die
Zeit man man hört auf realistisch zu
malen das was die Nazis dann später mit
allem Gift entartete Kunst genannt haben
die Psychoanalyse entsteht ja erklärt
eigentlich jeden Menschen für krank
jeder jeder besteht eigentlich nur noch
aus Pathologien wenn man Freud Folgen
durfte eine ganz andere Sichtweise und
das sind natürlich alles Sachen die die
antimodernisten ja bekämpft haben und
gesagt hat hier das die haben das alles
unter dem unter der Rubrik Dekadenz
betrachtet ja also alles was früher mal
gut war zählte auf einmal nicht mehr und
wenn solche radikalen schnellen Umbrüche
in einer Gesellschaft kommen dann tritt
wieder das auf was wir hier mal als
Ungleichzeitigkeit beschrieben haben ja
dann galoppiert die Zeit zumindestens in
den großen Städten unheimlich schnell
voran und die meisten Menschen kommen
nicht hinterher und da ist die Frage
haben wir nicht auch ein bisschen was
davon heute ne wir haben das einerseits
in der schon Taus diskutierten Frage
nach nach gender Race und so weiter wir
haben es auch die enormen technischen
Veränderungen die durch künstliche
Intelligenz noch lange gar nicht
durchgeschlagen sind auf den
Arbeitsmarkt aber sicher kommen werden
ja dass also viele Menschen sich
plötzlich in der Welt nicht mehr so
richtig zu Hause fühlen oder das Gefühl
haben das ist nicht mehr so meine Zeit
oder nicht mehr so meine Welt und das
ist schon etwas
das auch eine Parallele zu Weimar ist
vielleicht kann man sagen die Strukturen
sind wirklich andere als in Weimar aber
manches an der Stimmung ist vielleicht
vergleichbar ja so und wir haben schon
paar mal drüber gesprochen ne politische
Überzeugungen entstehen ja nicht durch
ganz rationales nachdenken analysieren
sondern durch Gefühle war schon im im im
vorrationalen Raum wie man so schön sagt
der Abneigungen Sehnsüchte ich meine
wenn du diese der Kulturkampf von heute
wenn du das mal liest in in dem Buch von
jener du du du du du kriegst den Mund
nicht mehr zu weil du das einums andere
Mal ein ums andere Mal diese Parallelen
siehst ja äh Mitte der 20er es geht
plötzlich wirtschaftlich aufwärts
Deutschland wird ein anderes Land Frauen
gehen auf Tennisplätze Frauen gehen
abends alleine aus schneiden sich die
Haare kurz denken plötzlich nicht mehrs
heiraten und Kinder kriegen unisex kommt
in Mode androgynes experimentelles ja
also genderfuid und so weiter boxhallen
entstehen riesiges Thema der Sport
entsteht der Sport entsteht der also
sowohl der Elitesport also die ganzen
Wettkämpfe wie auch der
Breitensport die ganze Körperkultur der
ewig unterdrückte Körper wird
freigesetzt Tanz ist ein großes Thema
ist ein großes Thema he alles wie heute
großstadver keh Büros das Warenhaus okay
Warenhäuser erlösungsfantasien die
Anthroposophie ja ja z.B ja ist auch was
Reformpädagogik alles Dinge wo wo man
gesagt haben wir haben das jetzt alles
100 Jahre lang falsch gemacht wir machen
jetzt alles von morgen an genau im
Gegenteil von dem was wir bisher gesagt
haben genau und dann total interessanter
Gedanke
die Beschreibung dass ich ein großer
Teil der deutschen und und auch da hast
du wieder die Parallele zu heute findet
sich in dieser Geschwindigkeit in diesem
Aufbruch nicht wieder die Entwertung
aller Werte sozusagen der der Untergang
des Abendlandes da sind wir wieder die
Herrschaft des billigen ja das ist genau
das und und du du schaust da drauf und
denkst ja ja das ist genau das Thema und
wir sollten uns das genau angucken weil
dann können wir glaube ich vieles lernen
für den Umgang heute für die Situation
heute ja es wäre so schön wenn die
Menschen ein bisschen aus sich
raustreten könnten und sich im Spiegel
all der Dinge über die wir hier reden
selbst betrachten ich ma das mal
manchmal wenn ich mich erwische dass ich
auch so melancholiekonservativ werde ne
dass ich so denke so denke ach war doch
noch schön als Familien alle miteinander
geredet haben und nicht die Kinder die
ganze Zeit auf Smartphone geguckt und so
es gibt ja so ziemlich viele Sachen die
ich so aufzählen konnte und dann muss
man immer ein Stück aus sich raustreten
und muss sich dann immer als Kind seiner
Zeit sehen genau ne also in der
Psychologie nennt man das ja den den
Ankerpunkt oder in der Marktforschung ne
in der Marktforschung guckt man immer
was hält jemand für einen realistischen
Preis für etwas und das ist meistens der
Preis als man der Ware das erste Mal
begegnet ist ja dann hat man gesagt okay
das ist jetzt angemessene Preis für ein
Stück Brot und wenn das sich wahnsinnig
stark verändert dann denken wir das ist
jetzt nicht mehr angemessen und so
bewerten wir ja ganz vieles ja wir
denken die Zeit als wir
jung waren ne das war noch eine richtige
Jugendkultur das war wirklich toll aber
guck dir mal heute an wie das ist und so
das heißt wir neigen immer dazu den
Ankerpunkt maßlos zu überschätzen ja und
alles was danach kommt eben als in
Anführungszeichen dekadenzphänomene
wahrzunehmen genau und dafür hilft es
natürlich und das gilt ja auch für die
politische Meinungsbildung sich nicht
nur eine Meinung zu bilden sondern sich
vielleicht auch eine Meinung darüber zu
bilden wie man sich seine Meinung
gebildet hat mhm das ist wahr und weißt
du was ganz schnell und nur letzter
Punkt aber weil es wichtig ist und ich
ich krieg das manchmal so mit die gerade
auch Kinder und Jugendliche die sind
völlig verunsichert und haben das Gefühl
oh mein Gott was passiert jetzt hier
gerade mit uns und so weiter und
irgendwelche finsteren Kräfte oder
gestalten übernehmen die Macht in diesem
Land jener weiß darauf hin und sagt es
gibt in der einfach in der politischen
Mechanik würde ich jetzt mal sagen gibt
es einen ganz großen einen zentralen
Unterschied meine Hitler wurde möglich
weil der Reichspräsident weil hintenburg
in quasi in letzter Konsequenz zum
Reichskanzler gemacht hat ja das ist
heute so nicht mehr möglich das G das
war eine wichtige wichtige Konsequenz ne
also hat Klausel ist ein ist ein
Schutzmechanismus und die Entmachtung
des Reichspräsidenten in der
haustierverniedlichung des
Bundespräsidenten ne ist sozusagen also
der Reichspräsident der we Republik war
ein Wolf ja und dagegen ist der
Bundespräsident heute ein schohündchen
der eigentlich keine besonders großen
Befugnisse mehr hat und auch nicht
direkt vom Volk gewählt wird so eine
beliebte Forderung warum kann man den
den Bundespräsidenten nicht direkt vom
Volk wählen einfach die Antwort ist
super einfach weil er so eine geringe
Bedeutung hat warum soll man eine Wahl
für so etwas vergleichsweise unwichtiges
organisieren wo die Leute dann alle zur
Weah gehen um eine Person die gar nicht
besonders viele Machtbefugnisse hat zu
wähen ja und und das hat was mit dieser
deutschen Geschichte zu tun würde immer
trotzdem sagen dass ein ein
Bundespräsident auch heute finde ich
eine hat eine wichtige Rolle eigentlich
sagen Rolle aber natürlich
direkt er muss über über nicht also
sagen wir mal so so nicht durch seine
Befugnisse ist er mächtigau sondern er
ist mächtig wenn er eine überzeugende
Persönlichkeit ist dann ist er ist ein
wichtiger demokratischer influenzer so
ich will es nur noch mal sagen weil das
wichtig ist sozusagen einer der ganz
großen Unterschiede zu damaligen Zeit
jener sagt das eben auch unsere
Demokratie heute ist so viel robuster ja
und in einer anderen verfastheit als
damals in Weimar und das auch der also
politisch zumindest der ganz große
Unterschied und insofern gibt's überhaup
keinen Grund den Kopf in den Sand zu
stecken oder wahlweise auch den Sand in
den Kopf matthus so seiner Zeit es
versucht hat Richard das hat Spaß
gemacht viel gelernt heute von dir dank
dir sehr ja ich danke dir auch also gut
ja Tschüss dan
C eine Produktion von mhoch2 und
podstars bei OMR im Auftrag des
[Musik]
ZDF